and that's why you should never stick
your hand inside a whale before you
leave I just want to say that one of you
is flunking the class this semester
Steve in the interest of privacy its you
wait I meant to say in the interest of
privacy I can't tell you who it is
I can't flunk this class my parents will
ground me listen I do have a solution it
sounds a little crazy crazy is good I
sometimes pour yoghurt on my dog's ass
why don't you try studying hmm
studying schoolwork work hard grades go
up feel better about myself no well I do
have another solution but it involves
doing a couple of favors I love doing
favors I'm a favored guy um if you know
party favors I come to your house into a
personal favor
[Music]
what are you doing uh nothing
dismissed I'm stuck I'm Professor rich
expert in science these are my devoted
students together with the aid of
harmless drugs we explore Sciences
greatest hypothetical questions
there are many things that change the
chemicals in your brain yes once I eat a
snowflake and there has to be an and the
bottom line is that there are many foods
that affect our brain like this Thank
You Stig let's apply this thought to our
hypothetical
what if milk yes go milk contains
tryptophan an amino acid that actually
makes us sleepy awesome give Mike a plus
please yes wait a second why is Steve
doing all this stuff for you did you
catch a masturbating or something Steve
is a little bit slow and lazy okay so
he's my new teacher's assistant
introduce yourself
hey assholes it's me don't mess around
with me or I'll sit on you
I don't feel high yet now after popping
a ladle full of xanax I decided to speak
to an expert who took milk seriously and
wore a hairnet so this is where the milk
is made okay and so I'm reading this it
says raw milk supply I'm assuming this
is where the raw milk supply comes in
yes
how does milk make us feel when we drink
it did it make you actually high or
intoxicated I don't think it necessarily
can make you higher and toxic in unless
maybe it's been out in the field or
something underneath the Sun or
something like that there might be a
post chemical reaction to the body that
way what about him does he work here um
shoot what is he still what are you
still doing here
class it's experiment time and I've got
asses of milk for each of you please
pick one up and drink there you go got a
little on you should what do you think
tastes like rum well that's because it
is dark Cuban Rome the simulation worked
not only was I wasted but addicted as
well I needed to get help what is it
that makes something more addictive than
another it's a combination of things so
one is just the rewarding properties of
it but just how it makes people feel if
someone does something with friends and
it's related to hanging out with those
friends they're more likely to keep
doing it
what about milk for example does that
give you some kind of euphoria ah sugar
can can activate the reward centers of
the brain but I don't know if milk can
you've been kind of skirting around the
issue I'm gonna ask you definitively how
does milk get you high no people have
been drinking milk for a very long time
we have a lot of data both anecdotal and
scientific that shows that milk
definitely does not have any
mind-altering or rewarding effects
so then I wound up eating stale
chick-fil-a out of a dumpster with no
pants on Wow looks cool no it is not
milk should be regulated like cars or
businesses or there's weird pedicure
places where the fish eat your feet
regulations exactly
Steve dance why are you - meaning
yourself like this because I'm failing
this class I have no other choice this
is a self grading class we're all
getting a pluses man is that true well I
may have forgotten to mention it no I
remember you specifically told us not to
tell scam rat
see unionized it's time to go come on
wait
[Music]
thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you
yeah you did a thing